hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round seven of the 2019 ranked
HS Classic Tournament it's Fabiano
Caruana
World Chess Championship Challenger the
formal one vs. are caught in a ditch and
we already seen one game where Carlsen
defeated eleven Arnon and again took the
lead so let's see how this game went and
we do have some nice footage from the
Greinke chess classic video team so
let's just check it out before enjoying
the game here we have a nice footage of
NIDA CH pondering on the position the
camera is a bit going around but that's
that's alright just for us to enjoy and
also we have some nice footage of
Caruana there you have it chilling in
front of some bananas apples grapefruits
there's some candy there some blurry
booze in the background just some you
know nice nice footage so there you have
it and yeah let's check out the game
karana has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 sorry about that we have nice to
have six
c4 and now e six and here Corona goes
for g3 so we will not be having the
Queens gambit declined karana opts for
some cattle and set up we have d5 by
black and Bishop to g2 and the Bishop to
b4 check karana blocks with Knight d2
and night each castles with Knight to f3
and D captures and c4 only now and it
this game will follow a game that karana
already played quran already played this
exact same setup in 2009 against the
sultan al maseeh where that game was
wrong and also in 2010 in Amsterdam
Corona played against Boris Gelfand
where Caruana lost this game so night
each came very well prepared Corona
castles with b5 now defending the c4
pawn and now pretty much always if black
decides to defend his c4 pawn you wanna
attack it attack the base of the pawn
chain with a flank pawn so a4 we have c6
now defending and now again b3 just once
again trying to break this pawn
structure we have c3 now attacking the
knight and now Knight the b1 and here
just Bishop to b7 developing and Queen
to c2
bye-bye Caruana and here Knight B to d7
was played in that game we mentioned the
sultan al maseeh yeah be on her own
again sultan al maseeh that ended in a
draw but here night each goes c5 and
it's not a new move it's just a move
that Khurana hasn't faced over the board
before Knight captures on c3 now finally
grabbing back that pawn that white
gambit seek actress on d4 and now Knight
captures on b5 we have Knight to c6 and
now there is one game in the database
where Bishop to b2 was played here
Khurana goes Queen to c4 and it is only
now as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game that's okay you're
pressuring the bishop here if the knight
ever moves you could threaten to
eliminate the defender of the bishop so
you do have to either move the bishop or
defended so Queen to e7 defending the
Bishop developing the Queen also
connecting rook standard the rooks can
now also be developed and now we have
Knight B captures on d4 and now black
could go into some series of trades but
Knight which wants to keep everything on
the board he's a very creative player
Knights to a5 and now Queen to b5 and
it's an excellent square for the Queen
pressuring the bishop pressuring deny
pressuring the other bishop so we don't
want the Queen to stay there forever
rook F to d8 night which develops the
rook and now comes Bishop to f4 just a
nice square for the bishop and here
bishop the c3 getting the bishop out of
this be Foursquare attacking the rook
and also pressuring the knight on d4 we
have rook a to c1 just getting the rook
out of harm's way threatening to capture
the bishop which would also eliminate
the defender of the night here so here
night each has to decide what to do here
it's a it's a very complicated position
and then there is one line which pretty
much forces the draw but it's a really
long line and it's hard to say if Knight
each consider that of course he has but
maybe he didn't like the outcome of a
overdraw endgame or or maybe he just
didn't feel like calculating all that
much
but there is this line of better
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
now Bishop captures and G to wear white
would have this in between rook to c7 as
that's why the bishop is on f4 Queen to
a3
pressuring the b3 porn kink actress
Angie to rook captures on d4 Queen
captures on a5 and now Queen captures on
b3 rook captures on a7 rook captures
Queen captures and now you can just
capture on a4 and you get the same game
where the material on the board is
completely equal white can even go for
this tricky rugby one move where you can
just trade Queens solid rock after
somebody three and you get the same game
where material is completely equal it's
a bit sharp against tonight with rooks
on the board four pounds each it's it's
possible it's hard to say if not each
saw this maybe he would like this the
same game with with the black against
Fabiana karana but he decides to keep
everything on the board he plays a six
kicks away the Queen Queen to e5 and
only now the C go for Bishop captures on
f3
we have Bishop captures and now Bishop
captures on d4 Queen captures an a5 and
now Knight to d5 preventing this Bishop
from attacking the rook on a 8 and now
karana finds a an excellent move and
that is Bishop to c7 just trying to get
this rook away from the defense of the
night then captures captures can happen
neither CH cannot leave the D file he
has to keep it there a rope to d7 and
now comes a III asking what do you want
to do with this Bishop but it also
allows an ID to improve his position
with Queen to f6 which he does now of
course he's hoping for captures and
captures on f3
but karana is not interested with Bishop
captures on d5 rook captures on d5 first
this comes with an attack on the Queen
so we don't have time to grab the bishop
here we need to be four and now comes
Bishop to b2 getting the rook Bishop out
of harm's way attacking the rook and c1
rook to c2 doesn't really matter as the
Queen guards the bishop for now but it
also means you cannot move the Queen for
as long as your bishop is and beat you
and now Knight it says let's just go
h5 my plan now is to go H for H 3 play
Queen f3 and checkmate you on the G 2
square
but Queen to b7 Khurana says ok you
don't have time for that I'm just gonna
push away your rook let's say rope to a
fate this was played in the game and now
just
Queen captures on a6 with this captured
Quran is now up two points and not only
that he has two connected passports on
the Queen side and those are very fast
as you all know so h4 by night is just
trying to you know get his plan to
fulfillment and Queen to c4 karana has
to keep an eye on the e4 or g4 square to
be able to prevent the black Queen from
reaching the f3 square so how do you
proceed here an I displayed h3 of course
still hoping for this queen of three to
g2 and the now Queen to g4 not allow in
Queen to f3 okay for the moment kuranes
queen is stuck there guarding the f3
square but he does have to connect the
past pawns and he will definitely start
pushing them rook to d3
going after the b3 pawn before by
Caruana and now rook to b3 and here a
corona said okay you're free to go for
my pawn I'm just gonna eliminate at this
point and you no longer have any sort of
an attack going on and rightfully he
does so because rook captures is
impossible due to Bishop d6 just winning
the exchange here so after Queen
captures on h3 we have looked to a8 and
now comes b5 just pushing that pawn and
it was actually in this position unmoved
33 that Arkadiy night is resigned the
game he no longer has any country play
he no longer has an attack and there's
really not all that much to do here if
you go for rook captures on a4 which is
possible it simply doesn't work because
here well it's it's a nice little tactic
feel free to pause the video and try to
see why you cannot capture on a4 I'll
give you a couple of seconds as it is a
very nice Sunday it's sunny outside you
know do do enjoy the position for those
of you who were able to do it you are an
excellent
you know creator of nasty discoveries
and for those you who just won't enjoyed
show just Bishop e5 of course now you
see that the Queen controls the entire
h-file black queen is under attack and
whatever you do rip the c8 will be will
be a deadly move so whatever you do
either you will wrap the bishop and you
will receive check which is also
checkmate
as the thing has nowhere to go or you
might try Queen to d8 yes you prevent a
group from reaching this CH square but
not just Bishop captures or route
captures it doesn't really matter you
can just capture capture capture and out
your up a piece you still have her
passport it's a completely winning
endgame for white so tonight it's
realize this and after this b5 by
Caruana he simply resigned the game an
excellent victory for Caruana and he
does as he is the winner of the Greinke
chess classic 2018 he's still trying to
catch up to Magnus we don't have the
standings here crossing after yet
another victory he's five and a half out
of 7 then Caruana in second place with
four and a half then Peter Svidler and
the maxima Sheila Gras with four with
three and a half we have vishwanathan
anand arkady knowledge and 11 oregon
which two and a half francisco pawns and
also in last place with two points
jeremiah and vincent climber Kaymer
after winning his game against Gehrig
Mayer he also drew against Lebanon and
in this round he drew against Peter
Svidler so it seems that those tough
runs in the beginning against cross and
karana on and the night each really paid
off as now Vincent seems unstoppable
so we'll see two more rounds to go what
will Vincent to do will be very
interesting to see I would like to think
Xavier Victoria Lucas Nova Harry Potter
urethane and aniket Modi for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and for the end of
this video let's just enjoy one more
time this is very suiting footage of
Caruana
chilling in front of some fruits and
booze so there you have it once again
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday